hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm currently in Las Vegas now why
I'm in Las Vegas you might ask well I
don't really know myself because I'm
supposed to be out here for a brand deal
but when I got here they just put me in
my hotel and no one has told me what I'm
supposed to be doing apparently there's
something happening later tonight but in
the meantime I'm gonna talk to you guys
because it's a happy Monday and thank
you guys so much for joining me by the
way I got new shoes check out are they
cool no this isn't the brand deal this
is just I'm really happy with these
shoes they're really cool oh my ankle
that thing was blinking I don't know if
something's blinking it this is a new
camera I don't even know if it's going
to turn out great because I just bought
it so that I could come out here and do
a vlog instead of doing it for my phone
because my phone is a little low quality
but it is all besides point what I'm
trying to say here is thank you guys so
much for joining me and I wanted to say
that I am sorry that for the past few
weeks videos have been sparse and all
over the place it's not because I've
been lazy or slacking off
in fact this vacation I'm actually
really happy that I'm having it because
these have been some stressful past few
weeks I'm trying to adapt my schedule
because I'm taking singing lessons two
times a week from this great great
teacher
Danny's teacher as well and it's just
phenomenal to be able to explore a new
aspect of what I can do and I'm actually
using it because just last week and
there's another reason why my schedule
has been so hectic just last week I had
to drive north up the Lancaster which is
about a little over an hour from where I
live to work with random encounters on a
music video about five nights at freddys
and it's really cool because I get to
sing in the video both videos there's
one gonna be on theirs and one going
yeah mine you're really gonna love it
but the problem with that was I got
there on the first night about 9 o'clock
because obviously I nights Freddy's is
played from 12:00 to 6:00
so I got there at 9:00 and we were doing
the shoot at night and we were there I
didn't get home until 5 a.m. so I was
really tired that day and it threw my
schedule for a complete loop and then we
had to come back again and I was working
from about 9:00 to 1:00 a.m. so on top
of the videos that I've tried have been
doing to keep up with everything that
I've been doing
and also other things that I can't
mention yet because I've worked with
someone just this past weekend and I
can't mention anything about it because
it's still secret until Comic Con and I
want to talk about it but dr. Ann dang a
gas so I had an all-day shoot with that
just a few days ago and that is why I've
been incredibly busy and videos have
been a little sporadic not that I don't
like to be busy but I don't like to keep
you guys in the dark it's unfortunate
and I don't want a camera on me at all
times in my life but it's unfortunate
because I really want to keep you guys
involved with what I'm doing and the
cool projects that I'm working on what
I'm working towards in the future but
it's sometimes hard to get that across
and live my own life you know what I
mean about that like it's hard to do
that and also stay sane at the same time
because I'm so spread thin over all the
stuff that I'm doing so that's why I'm
here in Las Vegas and frankly I forgot
to tell you guys said I was coming here
so this might be the first time that you
even knew I was coming here so while I'm
here I'm just going to be having some
fun and while I'm here oddly enough I
think I'm actually going to hit or we're
actually going to hit 8 million
subscribers while I'm here and that's
unbelievable I've been thinking about
that a lot over the past few weeks
because eight million is the number that
I never ever ever thought I'd get to as
far you know as I was going back three
years ago on YouTube I never imagined
that I would get to eight million
subscribers because back then who had
eight million subscribers woo needed
eight million subscribers but here we
are and I I just can't stop thanking you
guys we're not even a TV ok so
apparently this new camera can overheat
so I went out and got some ice in the
hotel ice bucket I set the camera in
there for a little bit so only I didn't
break everything and I have no idea
where it left up I think I was talking
about us hitting 8 million subscribers
in the next few days here and it's
really unfortunate because I didn't know
it was gonna be happening and I got busy
and I I am here in Vegas while it's
happening so I want to make a really
cool video while it's happening but I
don't know what I'm gonna be able to do
while I'm out here all of my videos are
back home I'm gonna have to figure
something out
figure something out I promise and it
will be special and it will be amazing
because apparently there are some other
youtubers here as well for this thing
that I'm doing in Las Vegas that I don't
know of so hopefully I'll be able to get
together with them maybe do something
really cool maybe do something really
lame but hey with my channel it's like a
50 fish goddammit it's like a 50/50
chance of cool and awesome right or cool
and bad I don't know what I can't
either way the point is I will get
something amazing for you guys because
you have done nothing but amazing for me
and you've done nothing but amazing for
everything that we want to do the
charity events have been going
fantastically and I'm so proud of what
you've done just last week I did a video
with Patrick out in Oregon for the
make-a-wish Foundation and I'm so happy
that I was it being able to do that it
was so weird because like this they
didn't tell me what I was doing until I
got there I was literally driven to the
house before I knew what I was doing so
I'm still like amazed that it happened
and I'm still amazed that I got the
chance to go to Oregon and see the
beautiful countryside there and just
hang out with Patrick who's a cool dude
and what's even more amazing is that
after I posted that video he got to like
150,000 subscribers in one day like it
put him like if there's like ranking
charts for how quickly people get
subscribers and he was like warmish way
up at number one for a long time and I
wish him nothing but the best he doesn't
even have his camera equipment yet he
can't even make videos yet but as soon
as he can I will do a collab with them
and it will be a lot of fun and I know
that there's another make-a-wish
Foundation thing going on but like a lot
of things in my life I don't have a lot
of details and I don't know what I'm
doing half the time I'm swinging it
totally willy-nilly over here so you
know but that's who I am so all in all
just thank you so much for putting up
with the randomness of my life I mean
that one video that I did Markab are
walking down the street that was
actually a video that I took while I was
in Oregon and it was so pretty
and I just wanted to capture the fact
that I was there and it was really
pretty but I knew that I couldn't just
throw up the video by itself because it
was it was
I really mean just walking down the
street awkwardly looking into my phone
and I just started editing it because I
found this MLG asset pack and I just
kept adding and adding and adding and
actually wasn't until I got back from
working with random cops because I
showed them the early cut that did not
have Shia LaBeouf going no so he told me
that I missed a golden opportunity so I
had to go back and then at like 2:30 in
the morning I was editing this video
trying to put Shia LaBeouf in the chow
to do it wherever I should and I worked
way too hard on it I put hours into that
but he's literally hours and hours in
that video refining it and it's still
probably crap but god damn it it's my
channel all post what videos are warm
damn it count oh man if I haven't been
doing that since I started my youtube
channel if I haven't been putting utter
crap on my channel since I started this
I don't know what I'm doing on YouTube
oh speaking of utter crap this video was
kind of suck that's perfect like I said
before I really don't know what I'm
doing in this vlog I'm just kind of
killing time until someone tells me what
to do but while I'm here I might as well
take the time to say thank you guys so
much cuz I wouldn't be able to do these
things
without you guys I know that and that's
why I'm so happy to work every single
second of my life I'm so happy to work
to make videos and I'm so happy to be
able to inspire you guys to go out there
and do something special in the world
and do something amazing i I've seen so
much creativity come out of this
community I've seen so much good will be
poured out from the community in that
that that is what makes it so special
you know in a time of pessimism on the
internet and at a time where everyone's
like uh everyone just sucks on anonymity
in the internet and everyone's just
hateful but I don't see that from you
guys you know I don't see hate coming
out of the community that we build here
I see nothing but love and understanding
and acceptance especially when I'm able
to do things like the make-a-wish thing
and going out and doing crazy videos
with other people and we're
with cool youtubers all the time and
looking forward towards the future and
being able to learn and get new skills
and be able to try singing and trying
music and I can't wait for you guys to
see the things that I having plans and I
can't wait to be able to talk about some
of them because some of them are really
cool on one go a guy but this guy stay
secret for now
so thank you guys so much for watching
thank you guys so much for supporting me
thank you so much for being here with me
all this time
like when we hit a million that's gonna
be fantastic but to be honest it's not
about the numbers it's about what we do
while we're here so just thank you guys
so much for watching and before my
camera overheats I'm gonna go so thanks
again everybody and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye
my don't overheat